hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in section 8 of his inquiry concerning
human understanding david hume
is going to finally approach the the
central question of that section which
is
are human volitions or willings
are they actually free in any sense
or are they necessary that would mean
they would be necessitated by
causes so let's think about what this
means when i
choose to do something for instance
giving a lecture on david hume
if we want to be a little bit reflexive
here and i
choose to walk from one part of the room
to the other
am i the one who's actually getting to
decide that
freely meaning i have multiple options
and i choose between them
or is there something that determined me
some cause or set of causes that said
let's take a walk right now across the
room
and now let's stay still or let's use
these words or this example
or let's continue on talking about david
hume rather than saying ah we're done
for the day
so one way of looking at it would be
well there's a lot of things going into
my
choices decisions my volitions but
ultimately there's a part of me that
gets to
make that decision and nothing else can
coerce it
it's as if you have a whole bunch of
counselors all of whom are saying do
this no do this you'll do this and
they're giving arguments
and then there's a king or you know a
decision maker who says well
okay i've heard everything that you're
going to say i'm choosing
this instead of this or is it
that we're kind of just along for the
ride
we do in fact do our actions
we do in fact in some way choose them
but the choice
has already been necessitated
by all these other factors that are
going into it these causes
and then we just do something you might
say a little extra in that
we're the locus of agency
and we do the thing that all these
causes led up to so it's not as if
we're totally superfluous but
we don't we don't really have full
decision making capacity
right and hume when he's finally getting
to the nut of this he says there's a
wrong end and a right
end to pick this up he really just talks
about the wrong end
he says it would seem that men begin at
the wrong end of the question concerning
liberty and necessity when they enter
upon it by examining the faculties of
the soul
the influence of the understanding and
the operations of the will
so they start out by looking at the
things that are
actually in some respect more murky and
who would he have in mind here
prime example would be a rationalist
like
rene descartes who says that you know we
can't really understand the body that
well let's focus
just on the mind and you know he does
this in meditation two and
three and four and five and then only
does he actually start in meditation six
getting back the body and he's like well
let's let's look at all these operations
work
meditation four there's a lot of
discussion of the will right there and
of the freedom of the will
and the idea that descartes has is that
it's easier to look
at the mind because the mind can
scrutinize itself and make sense out of
what's going on
and hume says no that's actually a
mistaken sort of approach we're not as
clear to ourselves as as we'd like to
think we don't have this this sort of
transparency that the cartesian cogito
had and so he says what's the right end
well we should examine
causation and necessity he says
instead let's discuss a more simple
question the question of the body
and brute unintelligent matter and see
whether we can form any idea of
causation and necessity
except that of a constant conjunction of
objects that's one part and
subsequent inference of the mind from
one to the other what we observe
is a constant conjunction so you know we
hit the billiard ball to use hume's
famous example
and the billiard ball hits another one
it communicates its
motion to the second one the second one
uh
you know starts flying off we didn't
actually see a communication emotion
that's the causality that we were
talking about there all we
really strictly observed is we hit the
pool you know
we hit the billiard ball we say pool
here in america right
with the queue and the ball goes off
hits another one and then the other one
moves
and it happens over and over and over
and over and over again
and so we have a constant conjunction
and similarly with other things you know
hume says
you're never going to find a case where
fire doesn't actually burn
whatever it's burning that's constant
conjunction so with material objects we
see that sort of thing
and then our mind is drawn when it
encounters one of these things to infer
the other so when i'm actually shooting
the pool
or billiard ball i hit it and i i expect
by inference custom habit that when that
first ball goes off and it collides with
the second ball
it will make the second ball work in
that way
when i pop a candy into my mouth
i expect there to be a sweetness and for
it to make me salivate
and for if i have a little bit of hunger
to be you know that assuage but if i
have a lot of hunger not
really right might actually awaken the
appetite why because i've done it over
and over and over and over again if i
poke myself in the eye
i know what to expect in that case too
so
hume says that that's the way that we
should understand material objects and
that's the way we should also
understand mind-body interactions and
then we should think about the
human mind itself
he says that
the if these circumstances be
universally acknowledged to take place
in the operation of the mind
the dispute is at an end at least it
must be owned to be
thenceforth merely verbal and he says
that
people make mistakes about this right it
says so long as we
rationally suppose we have some further
idea of necessity and causation
at the same time we can find nothing
further in the voluntary actions of the
mind there's no possibility of bringing
the question to any determinant issue
while we proceed on so erroneous a
supposition
the only thing we can do is to convince
ourselves that
all that we know of material causes is
the constant conjunction
inference and that we can similarly say
the same thing about the
mind so he's going to claim
that the actions of the will or the
operations of the will if we want to
reserve actions for the externalization
of that
are in fact necessitated by causes
and the causes that he sort of general
categories he talks about here
are motives we can talk about motives of
the personality or the will or whatever
circumstances are our reaction to to
outside things it doesn't make sense
for example for me to walk across the
room if there's actually a gaping pit
there
or a bear trap that i would step on
right that's a circumstance
and then character the character of the
the person
and we might add in some other things
there as well how your body's doing you
know
all of those sorts of things but he says
it is as
evident that these the the actions of
the will
have a regular conjunction with motives
and
circumstances and character and as we
always draw
in inferences from one to the other we
must be obliged he says to acknowledge
in words that necessity which we've
already avowed
in every deliberation of our lives and
in every step of our conduct
and behavior so he's saying that we
already do
assume that there is in fact
necessitation by these causes
and we have to acknowledge this
necessity in every deliberation of our
mind every time that we make a
decision we think that we're sort of
like weighing
options no the weighing has already
basically taken place and we're just
sort of ratifying one
or in all of our conduct and behavior
that we carry out in our our life
there's another consideration that
happens a little bit earlier in the
section that we should
mention a little bit which is that hume
asserts
quite uh strongly that there
is a not just a uniformity
of human nature across times across
cultures
but that this uniformity is also
universally acknowledged so this is
indeed a very strong set of claims
saying that basically people although
they're complicated
are the same everywhere and so because i
understand
my own human nature the human nature of
my group i can understand
the human natures of everybody else i
can predict their actions or
understand their actions after the fact
so i see their actions
and then i can say aha in these
circumstances this was probably
motivated by greed and i can even go
beyond the probability
and say i think it definitely was greed
or partisanship or
generosity or whatever passion or
motive we want to consider so that's
that's a really
important assertion on hume's part
that may be a bit controversial the
other thing that he says a little bit
earlier that i think is
is quite relevant here
is talking about um
what he calls a connected chain
of natural causes and voluntary actions
so hume says that when we consider
his words how aptly natural and moral
evidence linked together and form only
one chain of argument we shall make no
scruple to allow
that they are of the same nature and
derive from the same principle so
what he's saying here is if we think
that
causality and necessity works in the
external world of matter and bodies
we should also acknowledge
that it happens the same way with what
he's calling
moral evidence or uh voluntary actions
things that concern the will motives
your dispositions all those sorts of
things
and they form one single comprehensive
way of looking at things he uses the
metaphor of the chain where all the
links are basically
they might be colored different but
they're all the same metal right
so our our internal thoughts volitions
the actions of our mind are no
different than external things when it
comes to
these except that we happen to be
observing them from the inside
so he says that
there's this connected chain and the
mind feels no difference between them
and passing from one link to the other
nor is less certain of the future event
than if it were connected with the
objects present to the memory or senses
by a train of causes cemented together
by what we're pleased to cause a
physical necessity the same experienced
union has the same effect on the mind
whether the united objects be motives
volitions and actions or
figure and motion so he's saying
external things
bodies matter and what's going on in our
mind
it's all the same stuff it operates
more or less the same way we should come
back as well to talk about a possible
rebuttal of this that he handles in a
footnote he talks about people saying
well wait a second i actually have a
feeling
or experience of getting to choose
things
of a what he calls uh here we go a false
sensation
or seeming experience of liberty or
indifference in many of our actions he
says
the necessity of any action is not
properly speaking equality in the agent
but in any thinking or intelligent being
who may consider the action and it
consists chiefly in the determination of
their thoughts
to infer the existence of the action
from some preceding
objects and he says liberty when opposed
to necessity is nothing but the want of
that determination and a certain
looseness or indifference
when we feel in passing or not passing
from one idea
to another and then he says no no no we
we notice that in reflecting on human
action we really don't feel this very
often
and we can commonly infer actions with a
considerable certainty from their
motives
and from the disposition of the agent
but sometimes when we're performing the
actions we're sensible as something
like it and he and he goes on and he
says that you know people have this sort
of picturing to themselves
uh with the school people called
validities right willings
possibilities i could do a or i could do
b
and him says that's that's all fine but
none of that keeps you from actually
being necessitated to do b
you just don't realize that necessity so
we come then
finally to the question well what is
liberty then
don't don't we have any freedom of the
will and here's where you might say hume
you're really trying to have your cake
and eat it too
because hume says what's total necessity
but on the other hand also liberty
and he says the reason why people think
these are incompatible
is because they don't really understand
what liberty means
he says that um we cannot mean
that actions have so little connection
with motives inclinations
and circumstances that one does not
follow with a certain degree of
uniformity from another
and that one affords no inference by
which we can conclude the existence of
the other
so liberty can't mean that right it
can't mean it's like this total
randomness or you can pick anything you
like
so he says well okay what is liberty
then he tells us
liberty is a power of acting or not
acting according to the determinations
of the will that is if we choose to
remain at rest we may
if we choose to move we also may and he
says
this is universally acknowledged to
belong to anyone who's not a prisoner
and in chains so if you define liberty
that way
which you know you may not given that
that's not
usually how it's been uh defined
or understood you could better say okay
a lot of people can get behind this this
definition
a power of acting or not acting
according to the determinations of the
will
but the will itself for hume
is not free it's already
necessitated or caused by motives
inclinations circumstances character
all these sorts of things those go into
the deciding
so if you define liberty in that way
within a human context
you don't really get freedom of the will
you get something that's
called liberty and that liberty just
means
the will is able to you know create the
actions or or cause the actions that we
we see or it could be gestures
expressions whatever it is
and that chain of of necessity
causes the will to do as it does
so hume is really coming down hard on
the side of necessity
opening up a little space for what he
calls liberty
but ultimately the will is making its
choices determinations deliberations
on the basis of all sorts of causes
you